when I look at the work of frederick
wiseman i am immediately struck by the
power of his documentaries to force us
to sit with things that are
uncomfortable and challenging and yet
deeply compelling knowing exactly where
to put the camera to capture a precise
moment for maximum effect is a function
not only of consummate filmmaking skill
but deep empathy for his fellow man in
these times there is nothing more
important than empathy the only way we
are all going to get to a decent future
together is to look at things with our
hearts first whether they're ugly or
beautiful tragic or triumphant having
tried my hand as a documentary filmmaker
I understand how difficult it is so
seeing someone who does it so deftly so
skillfully is humbling
Frederick Wiseman's films feel so
correct that it can be hard to see how
difficult they must be to make he makes
the extraordinary look easy he lets the
audience tell the story to itself
Wiseman has an uncanny gift for knowing
the exact unobtrusive proper distance
from his subjects he may be a fly on the
wall but he always seems to know just
the right wall and that's amazing